i mean let's let's soak in a moment just
renewed for season two so many
congratulations
is this your first time at the vanity
fair oscars party my first time at the
vanity fair oscars party what a party it
is my goodness wow well as
you guys just said a big west philly
moment can we talk about the west philly
moment of the evening did you watch the
oscar i did watch the oscars and like
many of us i watched it all
let me just say it was a wonderful
ceremony there was a lot of beautiful
moments i just think it was actually one
of the best oscars i've seen in recent
times i will say
that
i hope that our
friends chris rock and bill smith can
reconcile later congrats to will smith
by the way for winning this award i'm
very proud of them i'm a west philly
native as well and i'm just super proud
of them and i kind of want to focus on
that part of the night because it's a
big deal for him and
you know i want to focus on that
yeah
i think we were all in such shock no one
knew
what to do and and you know now there's
going to be the online chatter and and
people are going to respond as they
should have done this we should have
done this what do you say to people when
they have a lot of opinions about the
seats i say you don't know
what's going on between two people and
maybe that was between them and i know
it's hard because it happened and the
internet happens and it's everyone's
business but i think it's their business
i'm just trying to
have a good time
by the way who are you wearing i see
them later and i'm like guys let's talk
about this
if if they walked in right now what do
you do i'd be like come on boys chris
well let's talk
because i feel both the comedian side
the west philly side i would talk we'd
have something to eat we'd have a good
time be all right we'll be over by the
way who are you wearing i'm wearing
custom dolce
it's a good gabbana it's a good sentence
i really want to say thank you to them
because being a small girl
getting you know stuff that fits exactly
right can be a little bit hard and dolce
gabbana has really taken the time to
fit me we ask everybody what's one
secret about your look one secret about
my look is i got to go to the dolce
gabbana showroom for the first time and
that was an experience felt like i was a
little girl in like a disney movie like
with a montage and everything it was so
sweet and they were so lovely and it was
a good time so yeah what i mean what a
year what a time it's been for you how
good did that season two renewal feel
and how have you felt about all the
praise some people calling this the next
office
i'm excited about people
having a show that they can feel good
about watching with their families again
that means a lot to me that's part of
why i created it i wanted everyone to
feel good watching it together so i'm
happy that we have another season of
television to be able to do that with
and as far as it being compared to these
big shows
clearly that's incredible and i'm very
humbled by that but i think ultimately
what people are relating to is that
feeling of watching a sitcom again a
brand new one that feeling of pop-in
pop-out television and just having joy
and laughs and that's really what i
wanted to
bring to the table so i'm happy that you
know we're doing this what ideas do you
have for season two where will things go
i just want people to have more fun more
laughs more labs more fun a good time
more heart
[Music]